That is my sister, Lily.
She jumps around on YouTube for a living.
Hearts and smarts!
And that's my sister, Margot.
She has a more sedentary lifestyle.
By the way, I don't normally sit around watching videos of my sister working out.
This is research for a bet.
I dare you to start your own fitness channel.
Okay, well, I would like to see you get more than zero friends.
You're on.
Let's do this, Vikings!
Cruel world!
How does dinner sound?
Alright.
Why would I ever watch you when I could just watch her?
You wanna be my friend?
This is completely impossible.
I can talk fitness all day.
Allie, can you help me up?
I'm not on the grid.
I have an idea that will totally reinvent book club.
Please leave.
Why can't running be more like walking or napping?
I think I might be jacked!